the new york times has been keeping
track of how many people in the u.s have
received one or both
of their shots okay check this out
17 of americans are fully vaccinated
37 percent have received at least one
of the two doses of vaccine now that's
just the big picture
but if you go on their website they have
a lot more statistics
some of them were pretty surprising for
example check this out
23 percent of vaccine recipients in new
york city brought their own
needle two percent of people knew about
the secret vaccine menu
where you can request the works and the
nurse will mix all three vaccines
six percent of people with drive through
vaccination sites worried about how
they'd get their butt cheeks up to the
window to receive the shot
100 of lin-manuel miranda sang i'm not
throwing away my shot
while getting vaccinated seven percent
of people told their families they were
headed out to look for the vaccine
and never returned oh 83 of tough guys
asked for that real vaccine you guys
gave the gorillas
men named cory were 25 more likely to
hold the nurse's hand while receiving
the shot
five percent of people who got the
vaccine in texas were accidentally given
a lethal injection oopsie thirty percent
of people getting the vaccine
accidentally wore long sleeves so now
they have to take their whole shirt off
in front of everyone at the pharmacy and
god damn it
i knew i should have been working out
during the pandemic
14 of senior citizens who thought they
were in line for a vaccine
wound up buying yeezy sneakers 35
of housewives elbowed their nurses and
said trust me i know what a little prick
feels like
then laughed themselves into a coughing
fit
22 percent of theater majors reported
chills and nausea
before getting the vaccine 39
of those who describe their jobs as
essential work with
t-shirt cannons 44 percent of vaccinated
people use the windows operating system
according to data gathered by bill gates
vaccine
chip implant and finally three percent
of patients offered to buy the dry ices
that the vaccine came in because they
operate a haunted mansion
okay that was very unhelpful that's what
we do